well now we have one in the high desert
of northern Chile
this is act the Atacama cosmology
telescope at 17,000 feet
it's the highest ground-based telescope
in the world I really like working in
the extreme environment of act it's very
very cold often and the wind blows
violently but the good thing about it
from our point of view is that the sky
is very very clear almost all the time
clear skies are important for axe
precise mirrors to focus on the earliest
galaxies what act were able to zoom in
with unprecedented detail on parts of
the sky we can also study the progress
of growth of structures where structures
are things like galaxies and clusters of
galaxies with the very fine scale detail
act doesn't detect visible light it
detects cosmic microwaves from the time
the universe was just a few hundred
thousand years old the telescope not
only detects early galaxies it actually
sees how they grew we're able to track
the progress of the formations of
galaxies and clusters of galaxies we see
the footprints of all the galaxies that
have grown been the time between when
the universe was a few hundred thousand
years old till now act has helped
astronomers understand how galaxies have
evolved since almost the beginning of
time itself